[Music]
Mass Effect Andromeda is the next
generation of action RPG brand-new epic
sci-fi adventure set in a vast
explorable galaxy
you are the Pathfinder hard Explorer
part soldier park guide and it's your
mission to find a new home for Humanity
[Music]
but in Andromeda resources are scarce
worlds are hazardous or outright
uninhabitable every planet has its own
story on this one
warring outlaw factions fight over every
available scrap you can make new allies
or enemies the choice is yours
not too shabby for folk who got kicked
off the station with nothing to show for
it
all I see is the trail of bodies they
left behind Sam tell me about Sloane
Kelly before joining the initiative as
head of Nexus security miss Kenny served
in the Alliance in the nearly spotless
record nearly she was involved in
multiple altercations with other
officers a hothead great what brings a
pathfinder to our humble port then to
Rev name ring any bells what's he to you
and don't lie to me just point me to
where you're holding him and there won't
be any trouble
there won't be drop it now you first get
out gonna put you down these worlds are
big so for the sake of time we're gonna
speed up our adventure there are many
paths to follow on this planet and
you'll need everything at your disposal
to survive whether it's a six wheel
drive Nomad which protects you from
hazards and enemies or the scanning and
analysis tools to help you interpret
everything you discover look for
anything that might lead us to the
killer the tracks make it look like an
ambush Fitz the rock our profile needs a
start
and garden blood matches your row car
theory Reyes keeps Kenny
we need hard evidence in a dangerous
alien galaxy desperate for resources
conflict is inevitable but you'll have
access to futuristic weapons gear and
powers to help you in your fight for a
new home
though you start out with a ship and the
nomad almost everything else you need
you'll have to find steel or craft
yourself and that's critical to your
survival these worlds have many dangers
from environmental hazards to hostile
wildlife
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
a new galaxy awaits how far will you go